let's talk about the mar-a-lago rate and
what happened there okay
so
at this point of the game you know the
story the people know the story it's
gone back and forth now they're saying
hey former fbi official says russian
chinese and iranian spies could have
tried to infiltrate trump's mar-a-lago
residence this is an insider story which
i believe is
said by peter strzok the same guy was
talking to you about earlier
uh who was once the deputy director of
fbi's counterintelligence division said
that it is likely that foreign agents
from russia china tried to infiltrate
former trump's former president trump's
mar-a-lago residents considering the
top-secret documents that were being
kept there strzok was fired from the
agency for sending anti-trump texts
on his work phone absolutely the
russians but not the russians alone any
contempt foreign intelligence services
whether that's uh those belonging to
china those belonging to iran to cuba
certainly including russia are all were
very inter were interested and are
interested in gaining access to
mar-a-lago he said
especially concerning
the lack of any sort of control and
memorization
uh memorialization of who had access to
mar-a-lago at any given time so when you
hear something like that and what
happened with mar-a-lago first of all
just the position that they took where
you know biden says oh we had no clue
about it this is not something we knew
about it you know and then garland is
the only one i know nothing about it
it's not my project somebody else's yeah
okay there is eight billion people in
the world there's only one other guy
that's a former president
if somebody raids that guy who was your
inanimate you know he's your enemy he's
the guy that you don't want to go up
against you knew nothing about it
none of that was disclosed to you and
then when they give the affidavit you
saw what came out with all the black
bars and you know nothing is wanting to
be disclosed
for someone like you who's in the world
what how are you processing what
happened here with mar-a-lago so trump
has been a target of investigations
since the time he was running for
president in 2016. this is just the next
this is a predictable breadcrumb in that
long-term trail right do i there's a
there's a um a tool that we use at the
agency called harem's razor and harem's
razor tells us to never subscribe to
conspiracy
what can be explained through
incompetence
so never subscribe to conspiracy what
can be explained through incompetence so
do i believe that biden knew that this
was going to happen
probably not
he maybe it was on a list somewhere that
got buried on the bottom of his 10-page
list and he just never got to it maybe
he was supposed to be briefed and
someone didn't brief him maybe the
department of justice which falls under
the judicial branch of government
actually decided not to tell him because
he is the executive branch of government
and we have three different branches
that don't have to communicate
everything to each other so who knows
how it turned out but i don't see
conspiracy in this what i see in this is
a continuation of the same sort of
hunting behavior to find enough evidence
to bring some kind of criminal
prosecution against trump that sticks
and it's the same thing that we did for
a long time against hillary clinton so
this is just unfortunately this is the
this is the
the world of politics that americans are
going to live in for a while as we try
to mix executive branch and judicial
branch and keep trying to hunt down
politicians and business people acting
like businessmen and politicians
how much is this is political
incentivization versus actual all right
let's figure out the truth here in your
opinion i think a lot of it is political
i don't think the truth is something
that that the government is particularly
interested in when it comes to trump
they either know the truth
to a high enough probability that
that they can make their decisions
moving forward or they don't know the
truth but they also can't just ignore it
to just ignore it would mean to
basically let go of all of the time and
all of the money and all of the effort
that they've put into it so far and
let's not forget trump is still an
extremely powerful player in republican
politics extremely powerful player
whether he runs for president or not
what he says about a candidate
transforms that candidate's
opportunities
you brought up hillary clinton and i
assume you're talking about the
the parallel between her email server
and top security information and this
exact same scenario with trump what's
the parallel you're seeing there people
hunt people try to hunt down some sort
of judicial criminal action to to
either eradicate or neutralize the
threat of that politician it's just i
mean whether we the stuff that we saw in
2016 on just the democratic side was
horrible we saw the clinton campaign we
saw the democratic national convention
undermine sanders intentionally when he
was running against clinton
like that that is manipulation of
politics all day long the idea that the
voter gets the ultimate say yes that's
true but then you also have things like
in 2020 when instagram decided to start
telling everybody as soon as you log
into instagram soon as you opened up the
app register to vote click here to
register to vote it was pushing
registrations to vote of the audience
that that they knew was on instagram
which is a certain age demographic a
certain socioeconomic demographic et
cetera et cetera et cetera which i mean
that was common that's this is the world
that we're living in now as everybody
starts to get so heavily involved in
politics um and we start seeing
conspiracy everywhere when what we
really need to be accepting is like this
is america's adolescence we're not a
mature country we're just over 200 years
old we're not mature china's 4 000 years
old
right we're we're coming into our
adolescence growing pains and hair in
new parts of our body that we never saw
before remember how terrible that felt
when you couldn't wear sweatpants to
school anymore that's a horrible feeling
for a dude that's where we are right now
when we've got like 50 to 100 years of
adolescence coming up and this is the
kind of garbage we're gonna have to deal
with
yeah i have i
and by the way i understand what you're
saying on on the truth um
conspiracies
um
have a very hard time believing that the
president didn't know they were going to
be doing this
very very hard time believing
you're again
for example like lebron james
who are the people
that he's gonna know everything that's
going on with those people
michael jordan's probably one of them
because he's trying to pass up michael
jordan okay like he probably sees
everything that's going on with michael
okay all right barack obama
who was he seeing that's you know what's
going on with anything with them he
probably followed everything that was
going on with the clintons because you
know behind closed doors they're
apparently big competitors and he was
probably following everything was going
on with trump even when he gave that one
speech from stage
you know and he did the tweet and you
know trump said this about you on jimmy
fallon or kamino says at least
i will go down as being the president
you know you won't be a president to
trump because president yeah so you know
you know hey elections have consequences
and obama looks to the left he's right
you know so i have a hard time believing
in the game of competition
that you don't know that they're doing
this or i didn't know this was going on
and when you say you don't know what's
going on do you know how pathetic you
look as a leader
wait let me get this straight you did
not do that that's going on yeah man
what a kind of a leader are you that you
don't know this kind of stuff is going
on if you don't know what's going on
with him maybe you shouldn't be in
office because a person that should know
what's
in office should have known that this is
going on
yeah it's it's
both ways no matter what direction you
say i didn't know i did know it's it
doesn't look good for anybody no i agree
i agree with that it doesn't look good
for anybody there's a you keep there's a
word that you uh that you used quite a
bit in that explanation right the word
was probably
and the core the core word in probably
is probable the root word is probable
probable refers to probability
so when so what the word probably
actually means is there is a high
probability that such and such is true
yeah i absolutely agree with you there
is a probability that biden knew
i just don't know that it's a high
probability 51 versus 49
i think there's a very high probability
someone tried to communicate it to him
but i don't know that there's a high
probability he actually knew on all the
things on that dude's list
the lowest presidential approval ratings
in history
in history the lowest presidential
approval ratings ever
that dude's got a whole lot of crap on
his plate and maybe the mar-a-lago raid
didn't make the top of his sheet that
day
all right i mean i've seen the
presidential daily brief the pdb that
they get every day they don't get
through the pdb every day
every they can't it's like 100 pages
every single day right about all the
biggest threats facing america
the mar-a-lago rate is not a threat to
america
right so even if it was in there
buried under iran and they're posturing
about nuclear weapons and north korea
launching a weapon and what's gonna
happen in china right now and what's
russia doing in ukraine and what's syria
looking like right now and what's gonna
happen in yemen what's gonna happen in
in libya like think about the headache
the president has every day is one of
the reasons why no matter how you feel
about trump you gotta respect the fact
that he sat in that seat for four years
that's everybody who takes that
presidential seat
that is a massive they age look at what
happened to obama look at what happened
to bush
they age so fast because that is a that
is a [ __ ] seat to sit in so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]